explícanos y hablar de consultas
cercanas con las autoridades afganas
significa que la misión de la onu
reconoce o no a los talibanes
de hecho revelado e iván del presidente
kan y la comunidad internacional no
reconoce a los talibanes como un
gobierno y la resolución del consejo de
seguridad es muy clara
como dice no mencionan los talibanes
pero hablan de la necesidad de buscar un
arreglo que integre a toda la sociedad
que defienda los derechos de la mujer
que proteja los derechos humanos de los
niños en fin es un recordatorio fuerte a
los talibanes que la única manera de
encontrar una vía para que sean
eventualmente reconocidos si ese fuese
el caso es un cambio total en su
comportamiento político señor aria y
cuáles son las nuevas dificultades que
enfrentará la misión política de la onu
en afganistán ahora que los talibanes
están al mando el problema más serio es
un problema económico es un país en una
ruptura de su sistema económico que
generalmente dependía de la ayuda
norteamericana en los años que ocupaban
en afganistán ese es el principal
problema que por supuesto ha creado una
crisis humanitaria de una dimensión
extraordinaria que el mundo no conoce
también como conoces otros lugares del
mundo porque ha nacido
suficientemente delgada y al mismo
tiempo se ha reiniciado en la
discriminación entre un su violencia
contra las mujeres los niños lo cual
choca fundamentalmente contra cualquier
norma del ingreso de un país hacen
miembro de las naciones unidas y el
consejo de seguridad- prorrogó su misión
sin preguntarle a afganistán y fue por
eso que rusia se abstuvo de votar la
resolución que tan común es que las
misiones se extiendan sin la opinión del
país donde se realizan
bueno la verdad que es único para que
afganistán también es un caso único es
un caso donde evidentemente los
talibanes están aparentemente en control
del territorio lo cual sería una
condición primaria para reconocerlo pero
bueno tiempo son reconocidos como una
fuerza como la violencia extraordinaria
que amenaza toda viola toda la norma
entonces por lo tanto a pesar de que
ejerce bastante control sobre su
territorio no se puede considerar eso
como una condición para ser aceptado
como miembro de nación